you've been involved before yeah like
once
i have been a horrible girl i've been
very naughty
i have broken so many hearts and i loved
every minute of it i really did
i was told once by my best friend's mom
to ride every ride until it's over
all right heather heather oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
american fork utah utah yeah it was
when i was growing up it was rural but
it was always ghetto
there was always drugs there was always
guns there was always gangs in utah yeah
wow yeah and tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents as a
kid
yeah but i hated my childhood and i
hated that my parents wouldn't get
divorced
and that cps was never called i would
pray for that what kind of stuff was
going on
uh you know i have a lot of [ __ ] now
from the ptsd like that started at three
um my earliest memories are like three
four years old
and it was all anxiety panic attacks
tripping on adult [ __ ]
because i was already trying to raise
kids you know and
parents and keep everybody okay
in the family taking that [ __ ] upon
myself which
i don't know why i did that but i was
there was a lot of abuse
um mental physical really bad like you
know i remember being
four years old probably and closed fist
punch by my father
you know i remember not liking what we
were having for dinner one night and
getting thrown down the back stairs by
my hair
you know it's like
that sounds rough yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
i went to an alternative high school for
bad kids
and i would go clock in and leave and go
sell dope with my gangbanger
you know straight family nice
yeah did you get through high school
yeah i actually graduated almost on time
i was like a month after my graduating
class
did it through the mail as well after
that and then um
and then i tried to go on to college and
it wasn't accredited
so i had to get my ged anyway so i mean
i over [ __ ] excelled
i was always brilliant and like really
intelligent i didn't have to go to
school one day a month and i could pass
every test
and how did you get into this kind of
work you know honestly
i i tried not to but i was stuck in mesa
for so long and
i got really upset with the women
disrespecting themselves to the level
they were
because if my first job willing to do
this type of [ __ ] which is beneath me
okay and i say it that way because every
female should feel that way
they are beautiful and they they let
these disgusting ass men do some [ __ ]
you know that's just disrespectful as
hell and i wouldn't allow that [ __ ]
i don't allow men to act that way i
don't i don't care how big he is i will
[ __ ] wreck him
you know you're talking about the tricks
of the pimps every man yeah it don't
matter who he is what he's holding i
don't care if he got a gun my dad raised
me with those [ __ ] things i can
disarm a man in seconds
and they don't expect it from this this
[ __ ] you know i wanted females to see
this is how you can do it like respect
yourself a little bit for [ __ ] sake
we might be addicts we might be out here
on the street but we can have dignity
you know because when i was growing up
in the 90s on the street with my street
family like that's the one
number one thing that you always have to
have in my [ __ ] street family is
dignity
and integrity and [ __ ] morals and
values your moral compass
does not change because you are addicted
you're the same person
you don't matter if your family's white
and they're [ __ ] living in suburbia
and they're mormons and they don't agree
with your choices
you don't agree with all your choices
either but it don't mean you're a bad
person it just means you're an addict
you know drugs are part of your life
yeah when did that start
12 years old i have many multiple like
i have multiple personalities bipolar
borderline personality
i have schizo tendencies paranoia
every anxiety disorder including
agoraphobia and ptsd
um ptsd nightmares reliving and
dissociative
disorder now i have an anti anti
anti-social anxiety disorder as well
where do you think that all this stems
from
you know i know the doctors and i've
studied
i've been to college multiple times i
know from psychology and the brain the
way it works
it was how i dealt with my trauma
because i didn't give myself a choice
if god put me in in the scenarios that
he did
at such a young age five years old
happened to raise kids because my mom is
too lazy and sick in the head
to collect a paycheck on a bunch of kids
she's taken care of right
she's having me and my sister that's
eight years old while i'm five take care
of these kids all day
she collects the paycheck you see
because that was our duty
she was real disrespectful our whole
life we were raised to be respectful
and to demand respect but we were never
given it from our family
we disrespected the hell out of
everybody
except each other like me and shannon we
showed each other respect because we
hated that
like i never understood how you can be
so stupid in your head as an
as a parent that you're trying to
instill in me
respect and respect elders and adults
and everybody
but you are disrespecting the hell out
of me every day
you know and then my mom she always had
issues with me
she really did and i don't know why i
was born premature
and she did drink every night and she
admitted that and
a long story short like i never got
learning development issues from
anything that she did but i almost died
at birth you know
and like she never after
i don't even remember age of three love
genuine love from my mom
she was jealous she was hateful she was
ignorant
and she would like have to force him i
love you out you know
at i'm six years old and she'd do side
hugs that were half-assed
she started telling me at five years old
i was fat and this is like
it was so bad like i had a really fast
metabolism my whole life in school i got
made fun of
because i was too thin they thought i
had an eating disorder already
and i would be so hungry that if i ate
three
three pieces of bread after school that
day sometimes i get beat sometimes i
just get yelled at
sometimes it would just be stress
everywhere in the [ __ ] house because
we didn't have a dollar
or 88 cents to replace that loaf of
bread do you see through that
behavior from your mom did you see what
i had to it took it took until 30 years
old and what did you see
i just know that she's sick and she
doesn't remember things the way that i
do because
i somehow am just i'm just built
differently but
her inability to love you is yeah like
she had her own
problems growing up she wasn't nurtured
the way she needed
for her temperament type and i get that
but she's also made up lies about
family members that disgrace me yeah but
this is how it gets
treated you know yeah yeah because she
wanted people to feel pity for her right
you know and that to me is like typical
[ __ ] behavior i don't act like a
typical female
i pride myself on that [ __ ] i'm logical
not emotional
i get emotional very rare times in my
[ __ ] life
because i always go to logic it has to
make sense to me
because the only way of thinking for me
is is logical like
how are you going to tell me that it's
good in in life right now that you're
freaking out
emotionally you know like you're telling
me you're right because you're a female
and you're emotional
i don't give a [ __ ] the world doesn't
give a [ __ ] you have to process your
emotions
and i am not responsible for those
[ __ ] you know
it's not it's not my problem if if
[ __ ] are insecure and [ __ ]
a lot of that's their own problem and
their own fault with their own men i
dealt with that [ __ ] my whole life but i
didn't put it off on other people
like with my mom i until i was 30
because i got into drug court okay i
racked up a couple felonies
a lot i'm like up to first degree
felonies in utah on drug possession
charges
i was trying to make everybody proud
because they knew i could get clean and
everything because i started using
method 12
and then i got myself clean at 17 years
old because i started having really bad
seizures and it scared my friends
i almost broke my neck on a chair and i
was doing this [ __ ] where my brain was
malfunctioning
in a room full of people doing a
shitload of crank
and i would not have any control over my
body
but i didn't let anybody around me see
that [ __ ]
i don't know how i managed that [ __ ] but
it was scary it wasn't it wasn't okay
like you shouldn't be able to do that
and i don't even know how i looked at
the time you know like that was just my
perception
so i got clean i had xanax and i had
cerequil and i took three days of
sleeping and eating and sleeping and
eating
and i was clean for like seven years i
relapsed once or twice in that seven
years
i was raising my babies i was just being
a good mom college student all that [ __ ]
how many kids you have three and you
raised them
um i didn't get to raise my son
and who's raising them now my parents
yeah that one was rough
i had actually stayed away from opiates
most of my life um
because of friends
and uh i i was
uh i have a lot of health problems and
basically i would get so much muscle i
would get so much inflammation in my
muscles
because i have fibromyalgia and
rheumatoid arthritis
they would flare up at the same time or
one would trigger the other
diet or just stress you know
i hated my husband at the time i never
wanted to marry him he was always an
abusive bastard and i hated his [ __ ]
guts
but i got pregnant and that's what you
do i wanted to make my grandpa proud you
know
because in hispanic culture if you get
pregnant
you get married i knew i could divorce
him so i was still in control you know
so i was like fine it's whatever i get
to look pretty in a dress
so that they can like you know love that
[ __ ] because it's never happened
again because i don't believe in
marriage you shouldn't have to sign a
paper
legally binding you to another person to
tell that person how you feel about them
you'd be showing that person every every
moment you're together
and i learned that from what i watched
with my parents
because my dad would never raise a hand
to my mom but he would stand by what she
said so even when she was lying and
she's telling him that i did something
disrespecting her usually in some way
when i didn't
he would never listen to me because i
was the child so then
that's when i would get beat that's why
she would do it because somehow she
liked that [ __ ]
but she only did that with me then when
shannon got older and
i was 12 shannon was 15. shannon was
overweight
most of her life till adulthood and
she started losing weight at 15 16 years
old but that was when my mom had gastric
bypass
and she looked terrible she was not as
heavy but she looked terrible
you know she wasn't taking care of [ __ ]
but she beat the [ __ ] out of my sister
one day and tried to kick her out the
house
because she was overweight that's what i
walked in on my mom
saying to my sister i flipped the [ __ ]
out
the [ __ ] out and my dad never even found
out
because i scared the [ __ ] out of that
woman and she was a psychotic [ __ ]
my mom was sadistic crazy evil and i i
just wasn't gonna let her kick my
[ __ ] sister out because shannon was
gonna do it she was gonna pack her [ __ ]
and leave
you know her mom's punching her telling
her how fat she is and worthless
you know like i flipped out i was like
get your [ __ ] hands off my sister
you're not gonna [ __ ] talk to her
that way you apologize she ain't [ __ ]
going nowhere and i will tell dad every
[ __ ] thing
you stupid [ __ ] what's [ __ ] wrong
with you you don't do that to your
daughter
you know i never understood that because
you can be sick of the head because i'm
sick in the head but i never
tried to break down my daughters or my
son
my kids are spoiled as hell with
everything
so today they're being raised by my two
daughters are with their father and his
new wife
and their baby and that they're in
montana
and my son is with my mom and dad and
that's okay
i mean no but i don't have any say in
the matter and
at the time that i was fighting for
custody
i couldn't fight anymore my mom you see
had taken my kids my daughter's
two previous times without facts without
talking to me about [ __ ] first like a
person you know
and she'd always had some excuse being
afraid of me all this and yes i'm
aggressive and i will beat the [ __ ] out
of somebody but i will not touch
my mom i will tell her i'm going to and
i'll flip out and say
all types of crazy [ __ ] i won't put my
hands on my mom
i was raised better than that just
because i flip out you know and go all
psycho like i threw a dresser at the
window one day
i'm pretty sure it broke the
[ __ ] but
like that was the [ __ ] she should have
been putting me on meds for taking me to
the doctor you know
she wasn't doing that it's like as i
think back now it's like the
much housing syndrome or whatever like
it's like that was happening
with her and me and chad because she
needed attention
you feel me like she needed attention
from everybody
and she did it like a lot of females do
and that's what bothers me
because why can't you get attention in a
positive [ __ ] way
working your ass off not needing a
goddamn person
and giving everything you got instead of
feeding off a [ __ ] negativity and
[ __ ] and sitting on your ass and
trying to just look pretty
suck some guy's dick to get what you
want i don't do that
i won't i won't even get in a car with a
dude
if i don't feel something and i very
rarely honestly will even
do things sexually it's got to be the
right price it's got to be the right
dude it's got to be
all of it because i'm not i'm not happy
right now
and i didn't even do i did this out of
like being pushed
months and months in arizona you know
because i was being robbed every day
basically
but i will not change how i treat other
people i don't care if they stole from
me
i'm not going to switch up because
that's me being ingenuine to myself
you know if i start being negative to
them because of what they took for me
those are material things i get that
[ __ ] every day back
you know it's not my fault that they
can't take the opportunity when i'm
remaining nice and the same person
to be a better person and not the piece
of [ __ ] they've been being it's their
fault if they go to hell
i'm mine but i don't need to go with
them so that this kind of work started a
few
how many years ago and it's not even
been used it's been months
oh is that right yeah yeah i don't do
this like in utah i drug deal
that's why i have so many felonies oh is
that right because
i sold in three different counties i was
one of the top
two dealers with my ex in two of those
counties
my parents my mother was
approached by two detectives one day and
i
believe one was dea and
they basically told her she's got her
customers rolling on her
over and over all over the place she's
selling to every [ __ ] buddy
and you gotta help us get her like this
is not okay people are dying from this
and my mom's told her told him i don't
know how to help you
i don't know where she at that's your
job go find her
so they kept pulling my ass over but i
was too smart
i would never have an amount that i
couldn't hide
i would never have the inability to hide
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
i never got caught except for one time
when i got ratted on
for having it so i but it wasn't weight
it still wasn't weight so i never got
distribution but they were trying to get
me with that it's a stressful way to
live right
honestly i was the happiest then than
i've ever been i was in love but i was
stressed because
when my kids were getting taken i was
not using like that i did relapse on
meth before
but i wasn't using the whole pregnancy
like it wasn't this whole big thing my
man had
like lost his roofing job because he got
hurt
and that's what started it but he was
the opiate addict not me
i was trying to be a good parent because
he had two kids we were having a baby
together and i had two kids
so that's five i have health problems i
wanted to be
physical like better shape for the kids
during winter
so i started doing physical therapy and
i forgot that i was supposed i was told
by a doctor
that by age 24 my muscles would be
depleted to the point i was in a
i have to be in a wheelchair and i never
have been in a wheelchair
besides one time when they forced me to
sit in a [ __ ] wheelchair to get
wheeled to the
ambulance to be wheeled across the
street because that's how bad my lungs
were
and uh at 28 years old
they tested my muscles and it was that
of a 98 year old
that's how bad my muscles had
deteriorated from all the inflammation
i had a flare-up of arthritis and
fibromyalgia that lasted for
four months i could not walk to the
bathroom myself
that whole four months and my my man had
to carry me
it was it was horrible like it was
to feeling like i was in control of that
scenario a lot of the time even though
he was abusive
i would could do the same [ __ ] you know
like
i got charged twice for abusing the [ __ ]
out of that man
that particular man like
i uh i was no long i was weak i was
forced to be
weak my doctor wouldn't let me do
anything i couldn't read a book
i couldn't make my jewelry i couldn't do
anything in bed but lay there flat
because my muscles had to heal without
bends in them and [ __ ] so that
they would be stronger you seem fine now
yeah but a lot of that is my whole life
this has been
i haven't had my meds for nine months
mind you i don't even take
a bunch of meds i have been to college
for alternative medicine
um because i don't believe in western
medicine
man-made [ __ ] does not belong in the
human body
we don't know how to take it in god
didn't make us that way that's what he
gave us plants for
that's why we did all that research back
in the day you know my body doesn't take
man-made [ __ ] and handle it well but
what about crystal meth
that's that's the one thing like i've
that [ __ ] don't [ __ ] with me
i love it i've been called many times of
natural born tweaker
people will think that i am high as a
kite on meth and i'm
so i'm just high paced high anxiety
i got to be moving but that's a lot of
the pain a lot of that's pain i can't
stay
not moving it hurts it hurts
and how do you find sex work sex work
yeah i mean not not literally how do you
find it i mean how do you
how does your what's my experience yes
it's annoying to be honest with you i'm
not willing to
act like anything if i don't want your
dick in my mouth you're gonna know it
you may not know it till right before
then
but for whatever reason i will walk away
from your money
i don't need that [ __ ] i have lots of
talents i got lots of ways
i will walk away from a disrespectful
situation disrespecting the [ __ ] out of
that man making a goddamn point
walking away with my head held high
because i'm not gonna be these other
[ __ ] i'm not gonna
act like that dude wants me to act and
i'm not gonna give nobody the goddamn
girlfriend experience
you know because like to me sex is
something that's between two people it
is cherished and it is beautiful
i get that we all have needs men out
here they that's this is just a thing
but where i'm from how i was brought up
none of us did that none of our females
had to do that [ __ ]
you were a [ __ ] for your man because
that was your man you know like he
wasn't getting paid for [ __ ] you were
selling dope all day you had money
you had everything you wanted and you
because mama got it for herself
you know like that's the females i was
around
like that's what we taught our women
like i was never around gang members
that
that like you hear on the tv my men
didn't go out and kill other men
for [ __ ] and have fights and all
this no we took care of our own that's
what we were doing
that's what the [ __ ] street family
was made to do
it wasn't nothing about another [ __ ]
color we don't give a [ __ ] about what
they're doing
that's not our family unless they're
over here bugging our family we don't
give a [ __ ]
you know like that don't make no sense
to me all this [ __ ] on the news
i don't know so you're a renegade or you
work with them
huh you work with with somebody that
manages your money or no
i can't handle that i seriously i have a
problem with authority
that doesn't surprise me especially men
i need a man there
to help protect right and to help
enforce because i do have ptsd
very severe with men i expect to get hit
because i am a mouthy
son of a [ __ ] i don't stop my mouth for
nothing
if i feel it needs to be said i say it
just the way i feel it i can take a
punch
i played football my whole life i've
been lifting weights since i was 12.
i mean i i have always been
underestimated and i love that about
myself
i've never lost a fight and i don't
usually fight females
[Music]
what emotions come up for you right now
yeah
i don't know i uh i'm
very proud of myself
but
i don't really know you know i can't put
emotion like tags on that [ __ ] because i
hate emotions
i was raised to hide that [ __ ]
the only emotion that we were raised
being shown it was acceptable to show
was anger
and thrust like power you know like you
used anger
to instill fear in someone else
to have power over them like i was
taught that as a kid
you know i did that [ __ ] all the time
but i did it for the right reasons
i think i'm not saying i'm i'm great or
i'm a saint i am a psycho [ __ ]
and i do get out of pocket a lot but
most of my childhood i tried to use what
my dad was doing with me
in a good way because that's i don't
like how nature has
always like there's always got to be
somebody dying to feed this one so he
can live
i don't like that i try to change it and
i know that's nature
but god damn it everything is possible
you know everything has energy
everything that i do affects everybody
in this world whether they
agree with that or not or have the same
belief patterns or not
i believe and live the way i do because
that's how i'm at peace
i watch a grandpa die unable to speak
terrified to hell that he was going to
hell for something he didn't do
for nothing he was just an alcoholic he
was never a bad man he didn't do
anything bad
his wife used to beat the [ __ ] out of
him you know like he
provided for his family he said cuss
words to my mother once doing the dishes
at 16 years of age
that's her trauma
other people caused her trauma not the
people she's aiming at
and that's what bothers me because it's
indirect
there's a lot of suicide in my family a
lot of it
and
[Music]
most of the mental illness is on my
mom's side but we can't talk about that
because she won't admit it she tries to
deny
that she's mexican through and through
to please a sister she acts wider than
hell
um but then i don't know where
the [ __ ] tries to act like you were
just going to ignore
mental illness that's something mexican
does you know
they try to ignore that [ __ ] because
it's not real we're all just [ __ ]
you know we just deal with our [ __ ] you
just handle and you go on about your day
like
i've always just tried to explain myself
to her so she understands why i act
certain ways
and she won't take it like she just
takes it like i'm attacking her
like if i say something's wrong with my
daughter then that means something's
wrong with me and if something's wrong
with me then something's wrong with her
and she did something
and i never looked at it that way i
don't care i don't care anymore what you
did i just wanted to stay the fact so
everybody [ __ ] knew
you drank every day you didn't eat for
[ __ ] and you weren't happy when you were
pregnant with me
and that's part of what was killing me
inside your stomach
you know like that's all i was saying i
wasn't saying [ __ ]
i didn't even acknowledge
openly and have not really that my
mother even never hated me
but she did she hated me my whole life
and i know that she did because she
showed me and she made me feel that [ __ ]
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
i just have learned to not be ashamed of
anything
that i've been through or that i choose
to do
um i don't hide [ __ ] from nobody i
really don't because i feel like if i'm
doing that
i'm regretting something and i'm trying
to hide something from myself that i did
i don't want to do that i'm not going to
live my life
when i've already made the worst
decisions i could have and lost what's
most important to me
my whole reason for living i've lost
right so now
i'm not going to live regret [ __ ] if i
don't want to do it i ain't gonna do it
and i ain't gonna have a goddamn smile
if i don't want to
you know because i get sick of that [ __ ]
too people always say here
you know tell me to smile this and that
[ __ ] you
just because i look pleasing to you to
you
that's my biggest pain
what is doing this kind of work taught
you about human nature about men
have you learned anything about men i've
learned that i was sheltered
my whole life i was treated like a queen
i didn't know men could be so
disrespectful and disgusting
i knew that they would raise their hand
to a female sometimes that female
deserved it but she couldn't handle it
so i
literally don't care i would step in
without her knowledge
and have you know words with her man
about the [ __ ]
sometimes even fizz you know because i'm
not going to let them
just keep thinking they can do that [ __ ]
and she's going to take it because
that's what she's programmed to do
she's too weak you know
and that [ __ ] pisses me off because i
don't like people especially when you're
stronger or you have an upper hand
preying on the weak you know that's a
female i was raised with men
raising me up treating me like the queen
every goddamn day of my drug addiction
seriously i was never disrespected
but when i was disrespected it was
always somebody i knew
something i did not expect but i knew i
was in danger right before it happened
you know but i've been through some [ __ ]
but
that's th that's what i already knew i
was getting into
but i don't know i've seen some
i've seen men do some [ __ ] you know and
i'm just like really
like i'm a beautiful female right here
and you're really going to come at me
with that [ __ ]
like you should feel lucky and
privileged i'm even sitting here in your
presence right now
because my time is money and i do feel
that great i think very highly of myself
i am very intelligent i'm very
like i just you know i'm proud of who i
am and
and what i am and what i stand for
because it's never faltered
you've been involved before yeah like
once
i have been a horrible girl i've been
very naughty
i have broken so many hearts and i loved
every minute of it i really did
i was told once by my best friend's mom
to ride every ride until it's over
because i didn't used to believe in love
i didn't believe that you could have
one life spent with one person i didn't
think that was
because of human nature possible or that
it should be done
so i never put that limitation on myself
and then also i just don't morally agree
with
with marriage i think that you should
have those values
in your relationship already if you both
agree to signing a paper fine
but i don't see why the government has
to have [ __ ] to do with us
you know what i mean [ __ ] those guys
they ruined my credit after my divorce
[Music]
i had a 800 credit score yo now it's
like 620.
and you got into this kind of work just
because because of sheer force honestly
money got tight or
well yeah i'd get robbed my debit card
gets stolen everything would get taken
from me
okay if i fell asleep if i wasn't
looking i don't think like that
it don't matter how many times you rob
me of everything i'll get upset
sometimes i'll yell or i'll cry
or i'll not even care and i'll go get it
back because that's how i work
that's what my dad and my grandpa taught
me not to worry about you and your [ __ ]
you obviously needed it more than me so
god gonna help me and i'm gonna go get
some more you know
like it don't matter it's just money
it's just monetary it's all stuff
somebody can't replace people money got
tight your back was against the wall and
you
yeah because that was the only way to
make money like right then and
if like i said if i feel it with the
dude i'll do it the first job i did
my homeboy they reminded me of my family
my street family back in utah homeboy
came up to me and
he presented me with a customer and this
dude was fitting to meet all my
expectations he wasn't allowed to touch
uh he requested i'd be in my underwear
or naked
i was good with that and we just
conversed for an hour he did ask
a couple times if he could touch right
but i said no we'd already agreed on
that [ __ ] you ain't
i'll leave he paid for the hotel room
and he gave me 150 and dope
that was the first job to have a
conversation naked
yeah because that was what i was sick of
these females doing they'll take ten
dollars for
for head because because what you dope
sick i don't care
your daddy will you know like that's
jesus your mouth is worth more than that
it's gotta be
what do you make of these well no
they're not really pimps they're hoe
hustlers as we as one of my girls i
don't think too much of them
you know i'll give them my last three
dollars when they coming up to me acting
like a [ __ ] about it like oh my god can
i have a couple of dollars for
for standing here smelling like [ __ ] you
know i'll give him [ __ ] i'll give him my
[ __ ] money because i got more
it ain't about that it's i don't need
you looking like a full act and a fool
in my face smelling like [ __ ] and
alcohol
go act like a [ __ ] elsewhere my dad
raised me with high expectations of men
and so did my street family i was around
great man all the [ __ ] time
brave courage courageous [ __ ] men but
i can't handle these [ __ ] like
you don't treat people like that
regardless of female like you got me
[ __ ] up you think this [ __ ] gonna
stay here stay quiet it will be hard as
a renegade to
avoid those guys who are trying to
enforce their neighbors well i mean i'm
not like
walking around finding that [ __ ] you
know but if i
oversee or overhear some [ __ ] are you in
my face talking disrespectful [ __ ]
i must watch the man that i'm with and
let him take
you know the reigns for the first couple
minutes depending upon what you say and
where you at and what you
how disrespectful you come to me because
i don't care i have taken on
multiple men at 15 years of age and i
remember
not being a loser you know what i mean
like
i don't care they don't they don't
understand they underestimate
everything that i've done in my life
that tells me how to take down a man
three four times my size you've been in
l.a how long
just two days yeah be careful here yeah
i know everybody says that but this is
just like home there's just more
like ignorance yeah people aren't as
ignorant back home
i'm not sure la is is was the phoenix
you were in
no i was in mesa yeah la's a different
city
yeah the people are the same yeah just
be careful people are people but
yeah this has been going on here a long
time it's yeah
even the cops don't know what to do with
it sometimes yeah but what i see from
these cops
they they aren't doing their job they
don't want to be there they're doing it
for a paycheck
and for something to do during the day
you feel me like if they really gave a
[ __ ] like the cops back home well i
think all right i says would be
being hassled it don't matter how many
people there's all kinds of cops there
are all kinds of everything but
it's a difficult job for the cops
what's difficult right now yo they don't
do [ __ ] they watch me shoot heroin on
the street
uncovered yo and they continue about
their [ __ ] day
i think arresting one that's what i'm
saying that's [ __ ] it's not gonna
solve anything
where do you see yourself in five years
i will
be almost to the completion of
having a business license um
and all my degrees that i need to start
my holistic health care practice
in alternative medicine good for you
i wish you the best of luck heather
thank you so much
very interesting talk thank you be
careful out there
thanks